مساء الخير اهلا بكم نواصل وتغديتنا
الموسعه والعاجله للاحداث في السودان الذي
يعيش صراعا مستمرا تجعل السودانيين امام
مفترق طرق في الايام القادمه
ايام متخم بالرصاص والقصف المتبادل بين
قوات الجيش من جهه وقوات الدعم السريع من
جهه اخرى هدنه اصبحت من الماضي بعد خروقات
مستمره من الطرفين
174 مدنيا على الاقل راحوا ضحيه المواجهات
وفقا لنقابه اطباء السودان فضلا عن الف
واحد واربعين مصابا في احصائيات تتزايد مع
مرور الساعات في العاصمه الخرطوم تتواصل
الاشتباكات العنيفه في محيط القياده
العامه واندلعت حرائق في مطار الخرطوم بعد
انفجار خزانات لوقود الطائرات وافادت
وسائل اعلام سودانيه ان الجيش قطع اتصالات
الهواتف المحموله لقيادات الدعم السريع
وحرسهم الخاص ولعدد من الضباط والجنود
واشارت الصحيفه الى ان قوات الدعم السريع
فقدت في ساعات القتال الاولى المركز
الرئيسي للقياده والسيطره وفي سياقه
الهدنه اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع الموافقه
على هدنه لاربعه وعشرين ساعه
مساء اليوم حتى السادسه مساء الخير
ونتوقف الان مع هذا التقرير الخاص من مطار
مروي بعد اعلان الجيش السيطره عليه كان
ميرا العربيه تجولت في المطار وظهرت جزءا
من الدمار الذي لحق ببنيته التحتيه
العربيه والحدث في هذا اليوم الاربعاء
التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام 2023 داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه وداخل مطار مروي الدولي هذا
المطار الذي كان مسرحا لعمليات عسكريه
خلال خمسه ايام مضت هو الان بهذه الوضعيه
وبهذه الشاكله بعد اشتداد العمليات
العسكريه والحربيه والاشتباكات بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع
هذه الصور التي تتابعونها حصريا على
العربيه والحدث لاننا وصلنا الان قبل قليل
الى هذا المطار بعد ان اصبح بسيطره كامله
تحت قياده الجيش السوداني وتحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه السودانيه التي انتشرت عبر
الاليات وعبر المدفعيه وعبر الدبابات
الثقيله هذا هو المطار بوضعيته الراهنه
بعد خمسه ايام من عمليات عسكريه على اشدها
شهدتها هذه المنطقه وهذه القاعده العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه العملياتيه الجويه بشمال
السودان في منطقه مروي طائرات عسكريه حسب
ما نرى الان في الصوره لم تتضرر هنالك بعض
الطائرات تضررت هذا المكان الذي تشاهدونه
الان هو يقدم الخدمات اللوجستيه للطائرات
ايضا تضرر وتاثر بفعل الاشتباكات والضربات
العنيفه التي حدثت في هذه المنطقه الان
هذا المطار وهذا الجزء من المطار هو حيوي
يتعلق بهبوط بقيام الطائرات التدريبات
كانت في هذا المكان الان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تنتشر في محيط وفي ارجاء هذا
المكان تتمركز في مختلف الاتجاهات في
الاتجاه الشمالي في الاتجاه الجنوبي وفي
الاتجاه الغربي وفي الاتجاه الشرقي حسب
افادات خاصه للعربيه والحدث بان الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه السوداني الان
تفر بالكامل على كل مداخل ومخارج هذا
المطار والقاعده العملياتيه الجويه هنا في
مدينه مروي شمال السودان يوم الامس دارت
اشتباكات عنيفه على اثرها
غادرت قوات الدعم السريع واضطرت بحسب بيان
للجيش السوداني لمغادره هذه القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه شمالا بعدها
مباشره تعاملت الطيران او تعامل الطيران
الجيش السوداني مع من خرج من هذه القاعده
وكبدهم خسائر فادحه بحسب ايضا مصادر
عسكريه الان هذا المطار بكلياته بكامله في
يد الجيش السوداني ويد القوات المسلحه من
داخل مطار مروي الدولي ومن داخل القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه نزار لقناتي
العربيه والحدث
من مروي يبقى معنا مراسل العربيه
الجديد خالد هي حاله الهدوء النسبي التي
استمرت لاكثر من 12 ساعه هنا في هذه
الولايه الشماليه شمال السودان وفي محليه
مروي تحديدا هذا الهدوء جاء نتيجه لما قال
به الجيش السوداني بانسحاب وبخروج لقوات
الدعم السريع خرجت مضطره النتيجه
للاشتباكات العنيفه والاستخدام الطيران
والمدفعيه الثقيله خرجت قوات الدعم السريع
من محيط ومركز القاعده والمطار واصبحت
بالتالي خارج حدود محليه مروي الان هذه
الصوره خالد مباشره هي
احد الشوارع في مدينه مروي شمال السودان
حاله الهدوء النسبي هي الان تسيطر على
الاجواء
هدوء في الطرقات التجوال بسيط للمواطنين
لكن هنالك انسياب لحركه المواطنين بحكم
انهم الان يرتبون انفسهم للدخول في فتره
الاعداد
عيد الفطر المبارك وبالتالي يحاولون شراء
المستلزمات السوق الرئيس في هذه المدينه
الان بدا يعاود نشاطه رويدا رويدا اليس
بشكل كلي المقر الحكوميه على قرار ما
تشاهده الان خالد امام مباشره وحده مروي
الاداريه هي هذه الوحده معنيه بتنظيم
الامور التنفيذيه والخدميه في هذه المحليه
الان مغلقه
الموظفون والعاملون لم يصلوا الى هذه
المحليه بحكم الخوف وبحكم التوتر الذي
لازم هذه المنطقه خلال الايام الماضيه
ولكن حسب ما نشاهد وحسب ما نعاين بان
الامور الان بدات تعود الى طبيعتها الى
وضعيتها
المعتاده كثير من المواطنين الان بداوا في
التحرك في الشارع بداوا في
معاينه الطبيعه الاشياء ما الذي يدور وما
الذي حدث سنحاول خالد ان نستطلع احد
مواطنين محليه مروي ونتعرف على احساسه
وكيف يتابع هذه الاوضاع الامنيه السلام
عليكم السلام ورحمه الله
الاوضاع كيف عندكم الان والله الحمد لله
الامور كلها تمام
والحياه بقت عاديه وطبيعيه
والناس رجعت لي حياه الطبيعيه ان شاء الله
سوق كيف هلا سوق فتح بشكل كامل الحمد لله
لكن بخمسين في المئه او خمسه وخمسين او
60% والامور ان شاء الله من الليل اللي
بكره بترجع الاوضاع عادي ان شاء الله
خايفين ولا حاسين انه لسه في توتر والله
اليومين الاوائل الخوف كان موجود لكن
الحمد لله من امبارح واول مبارحة أول
الليله صار الصباح والليله الامور عاديه
والناس ان شاء الله كل الامور بدمش طيبه
وموافق خوف وما في توجس وما في توتر ان
شاء الله
مواطن مدينه مروي ماذا يقولون
لمن
يتحكم الان في المشهد سواء كان الجيش او
الجهات الاخرى الدعم السريع على العموم
الوضعيه العسكريه المعقده الان ما هي
رساله المواطنين في هذه المنطقه والله يا
اخي اصلا الحريم ما في زول
جانب الحرب
ونتمنى انه من
روايه الشعب المسلحه
والدعم السريع انه يحكموا صوت العقل وكل
السياسيين والقوه السياسيه انه الناس تقعد
في طاوله واحده
ويخرج هذه البلاد من هذا المازق الذي
تعيشه
وهذه
الحربران بل بالعكس كل الشعب السوداني منا
حيكون متضرر وخسران
الانتصار الوحيد والربح الوحيد بيكون في
انه تقعد وتطلع هذه البلاد من هذا المازق
ودي رسالتنا اللي بنقول اليوم لانه في
النهايه اللي بيموتوا من هنا او اللي
بيموت من هنا كلهم يعون اولاد الشعب
السوداني وكلهم يهون سودانيين والحرب ما
عندها نهايه بعد ما تبدا ونتمنى انه الناس
تحكم صوت العقل وتصل في النهايه للمفاوضات
هذه البلاد من هذه الحروب ان شاء الله تحت
هنا ان شاء الله لانكم ناس من الخرطوم ام
درمان ولا والله والله الناس جايه لكن
لحسب الشارع والظروف المتطلع الناس من
الخرطوم لكن ان شاء الله الامور العيد
بتعدي على الحقيقه انت برضو كمواطن يعني
في اقل من دقيقه في بعض المواطنين خرجوا
من مروي خلال يومين الماضيين هل عرفت انهم
رجعوا الان في ناس قطعوا الكبري والان بدو
يرجعوا والله فيديو كثير من الناس طلعوا
لكن من الليل اليوم الناس بدات تجي ترجع
وتمارس حياه الطبيعيه السنه جايه من منطقه
القرير جيت الصباح وهسه راجع
خالد ايضا اضيف اضافه لما قاله هذا
المواطن بولايه ولايه الشماليه بان هنالك
حاله من التلاحم والتضامن بين مواطني هذه
المنطقه والقوات المسلحه هم يقدموني يوميا
وجبه افطار رمضان للمصابين بمستشفى
العسكري هنا في مروي يقدمون وجبه الافطار
ويقدمون السند والعضد للقوات المسلحه
وللمصابين وايضا للمدنيين الذين اصيبوا هم
اعداد قليله ولكن كل المشهد الذي يقال حول
طبيعه التلاحم المجتمع بان هنالك توافق
بان هنالك تلاحم بان هنالك ترابط بين
الجيش وبين المواطنين وهذه الروح لمسناها
في اكثر من منطقه هنا في الولايه الشماليه
شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل العربيه نزار من
مدينه مروي
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر اه والله
[موسيقى]
والله
اكبر هلا والله
من الرياض مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
لينا يعقوب غنى اهلا بك
ببعض ما ذكرته المصادر العربيه بان هناك
حركه نزوح كبيره على وقع هذه الاشتباكات
من منطقه الخرطوم بحري نحو مدن اخرى ايضا
ما وضع هذه المدينه او الخرطوم البحري
اولا من ناحيه الجغرافيه
وما حجم الاشتباكات التي تجري فيها والتي
تدفع الناس الى النزوح منه
يعني ان اردت العبور من بحري او من كبري
او من جسر المكني من تجاه الخرطوم
بالسياره ربما تستغرق المده خمس دقائق فقط
هذا يعني انها قريبه هذا بالنسبه للمشاهد
العربي العاصمه الخرطوم هي اسمها العاصمه
المثلثه الخرطوم بحري وام درمان هذه
المناطق قريبه جدا من بعضها هي في الخرطوم
يربط بينها جسور بالامكان بعد ذلك
الانتقال طبعا الى ولايات مختلفه تبعا
لهذه الجهات وهذه المناطق حركه النزوح كما
اشار نزار قبل قليل مع احد الضيوف من
الشارع تعتمد على امان على الامانه
الموجود في الشارع
وسط الخرطوم الان فيه انتشار للدبابات
هناك مناطق تتمركز فيها دبابات تتبع الجيش
وهناك مناطق اخرى تنتشر فيها ايضا دبابات
تتبع
نعم الامر الاخر خالد وهو ايضا المهم وهو
انتشار السلاح قبل قليل
للجيش السوداني اشار الى ان هناك حمله
لبيع السلاح من قبل قوات الدعم السريع لدى
المواطنين الدعم السريع حتى اللحظه لم يرد
على هذه النقطه بعد ولكن نتوقع طبعا ان
يكون لديه رد لكن انتشار السلاح في يد
المواطنين كذلك نفاذ الاسلحه مثلا من قبل
الدعم السريع في مناطق قد تطرها للدخول
مثلا الى بعض المراكز
الشرطيه او الى مخازن للحصول على هذا
السلاح الجيش الان يسيطر على مخازن
للاسلحه بحسب المعلومات المتاحه لنا حتى
انه سيطر على مخازن للاسلحه تتبع للدعم
السريع من بينها مخزن موجود في جبل اولياء
بعد قليل قد ينتشر فيديو لهذا
لهذا المخزن فيه كثير من انواع الاسلحه
اذا انتشار السلاح يشعر المواطنين بعدم
الامان في الحركه لذلك يؤثر كثير من
المواطنين البقاء في منازلهم بدلا من الح
هو التعرض الى اي او الهروب او الهروب
والتعرض الى السرقات او اعتداء اذا ما
ارادوا الهروب من هذه المنطقه الخرطوم
بحري الى اي المدن يمكن ان يتوجهوا يعني
الاقرب ربما لنا يعني احنا ان تحدثنا مثلا
عن الخرطوم كنا نذهب مثلا بشارع هذا
الشارع الشارع مدني هذا الشارع ينم
بامكانك فيه ان تمر الى ولايات سودانيه
مختلفه يعني يمكن ان تذهب بعد ذلك الى
مدني الى القضارف الى شرق السودان كذلك في
ام درمان ان اخذت شارع عمران ستذهب الى
ولايات اخرى وكذلك في بحري اذا بامكان
المواطنين المتواجدين مثلا في هذه المناطق
الذهاب بالطرق الرئيسيه التي تؤدي الى
الولايه السودانيه ولكن حتى اللحظه لا
يوجد اي امان لدى المواطنين للحركه بصوره
طبيعيه فبحسب المعلومات لا توجد الان
البساطه السفريه
السفريه هي تعني السفر بين الولايات
السودانيه المختلفه وبين الخرطوم وهذه
الولايات هناك مينا اسمه المينا البري هذا
الميناء موجود في العاصمه الخرطوم بامكان
اي مواطن السفر الى اي ولايه سودانيه
الجزيره القضارف بورسودان الى حتى ولايات
دارفور ان تقطع تذكره بقيمه اقل طبعا
بكثير من قيمه الطائره والذهب حركه
الطيران في السودان ايضا هي ليست مع كل
الولايات السودانيه هناك ولايات قريبه من
العاصمه الخرطوم لا تحتاج ان تاخذ طائره
ولكن هناك ايضا طيران داخلي هذا الطيران
من الخرطوم الى ولايات دارفور الى كسلا
الى بورسود وهو ايضا معطل رغم ان المطارات
في الولايات غير معطله ولكن خطوط الطيران
تؤثر بان لا تقلع طائراتها من الولايات
السودانيه تجاه الخرطوم او حتى الى رحله
خارجيه
الحرب الان الحرب الشوارع في الخرطوم هل
يمكن الحديث
عن تكتيكات معينه سواء
لجيشه وحتى للدعم
السريع في هذه الحرب يعني ما الاولويه
بالنسبه للقوات الدعم السريعه الان عسكريا
في مثل هذه الاوضاع الان
الدعم السريع الان لديه حرب يخضها بطرق
مختلفه الجيش قال ايضا انه يعمل بتكتيكات
من بين هذه التكتيكات ان يحاصر الدعم
السريع في اماكن تواجده خاصه في تواجد
مثلا في القصر ان تواجد في تلفزيون
السودان في بعض المقال لا يقوم باستهداف
المباني بمعنى انه يعتمد على ان ينفذ
ما هو موجود في هذا المكان من غذاء
الاعتماد على قطع الكهرباء والمحاصره بطرق
مختلفه حتى يسلم هؤلاء الافراد انفسهم او
حتى يعني تحدث اشتباكات لكن لا تؤدي الى
دمار مثلا كامل الدعم السريع ايضا يعني هو
ينتهج طرق مختلفه هو صحيح يعلن ذلك في
بياناته ولكن ما رصدناه اليوم في بعض
الصفحات التي تتبع لمناشطين تتبع للجان
مقاومه تشير بصوره واضحه الى انتشار
عمليات السرقه والنهب والتخريب هناك محطات
وقود تم تخريبها هناك محطات كهرباء تم
تخريبها عمدا اي انها لم يحدث لها قصف
انما خربت بعد ذلك وهذا يشير الى ايضا عدم
الامن وانتشار بعض الجرائم في بعض المناطق
والنقاط الحيويه
لنبقي معي سنعود للمتابعه ايضا في ملفات
السودان والتطورات
في الجهد الاقليميه للتهديدات نذكر
بالاتصال الهاتفي بين وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ونظيره
الامريكي الذي اكد فيه على اهميه وقف
التصعيد العسكريه في السودان وضروره حمايه
المدنيين والاجانب وشدد ايضا على اهميه
الامن واستقرار السودان وشعبه قبل ذلك
السياقه كد وزير الخارجات المصري سامح
شكري لبلاده ستكثف الاتصالات مع الاطراف
السودانيه المتنازعه من اجل استئناف
الحوار السلمي للتسويه الوضع بينهما مصادر
خاصه للعربيه تحدثت عن تحركات مصريه
اقليميه تشمل الدخول مراقبين دوليين
للوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار خلال عيد
الفطر وفتح ممرات امنه بين مصر والسودان
لمده 48 ساعه للسماح بنقل المصابين ودخول
المساعدات الانسانيه وفيما يتعلق بالجنود
المصريين في مروي اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع
نقلهم الى العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت قوه
الدعم السريعين جميع الجنود المصريين بخير
ويتلقون الرعايه اللازمه وسيتم تسليمهم
متى ما سمحت الفرصه المناسبه لذلك
تخططه برلين لاجلاء نحو 150 مواطنا
المانيا من بينهم دبلوماسيون وعمال اغاثه
عركونا في الخرطوم بشكل سري صباح اليوم
وذلك بحسب موقع الالماني
الخارجيات الالمانيه الغت عمليه الاغاثه
بعد عمليه القصف الذي استهدف مطار الخرطوم
رغم وجود الطائره التابعه للجيش الالماني
في اليونان للاستعداد والتوجه الى
السوداني غدا ولم تعد ولم تعد اعاده جدول
جدوله اغاثه الالمانيين وتحديد موعد اخر
لاجلائه
ضم الينا سفر السودان في ابو ظبي السفير
عبد الرحمن شرفي سيد عبد الرحمن اهلا
وسهلا بكم معي
ما الدور الذي تقوم به ابو ظبي اليوم ويتم
التنسيق فيه معكم ومع سودانيين الان لربما
التعامل مع الازمه اليوم وايقاف هذه الحرب
تحياتي لكم المشاهدين الكرام
كما تعلم
حكومه المهارات العربيه
اكدت
واعلنت يعني دعمها
لهذه الازمه نحن في السودان على تواصل وفي
هذا الاماراتيه
وكما تعلم يعني
حاليا
بعمليات قدره غضب مسلحه ميناء هذا التمرد
وهي يعني كما كما هو واضح هي في مراحلها
الاخيره ان شاء الله
نحن نتمنى غريبا ان نحصل الامر وان تعود
الامور الى طبيعتها ان شاء الله لماذا
تقول انها في مراحلها الاخيره السيد عبد
الرحمن
كما تعلم القوات المسلحه تعمل
الان
تم بحر قوات التمرد من معظم انحاء العاصمه
والمناطق
الاخرى لمصلحه الصيف تماما على الاعضاء
ما يحدث هو حاليا
مطارده مطارده العاصمه
[موسيقى]
هل هناك جهود وساطه تبدل الان فعليا على
الارض تقوم بها
دول في المنطقه والاقليم
[موسيقى]
يعني هنالك الان
مجهود بحسب هذا التمرود يعني عسكريا
ومدروسه ونحن في السودان كما تعلم حريصون
دائما على على
سماح بالعمليات الانسانيه
هذا تقوم به قوات المسلحه الان
ولكن
عسكريا يعني على وشك ان يحسم
بعد هزيمه هذا التمر
وان شاء الله خلال الايام القادمه
تعود الامور الى ايمان
وتعود الحياه ان شاء الله
السفير عبد الرحمن يعني هناك البعض من
تحدث عن دور الامارات يعني او الابعاد
الادوار الاقليميه لبعض الدول في هذه
الحرب اليوم هناك من يرى بان الامارات
تنحاز لطرف دون اخر وتدعم طرفا بمعدات
واسلحه متطوره يتحدثون هنا عن حميتي وقوات
الدعم السريع
ولمحاربه الجيش السوداني حقيقه الموقف سيد
عبد الرحمن شرق
علاقات وثيقه وطيبه جدا وقديمه وراثيقه
لدوله الامارات موظف الامارات دائما
معروفه وهي يعني مواقف داعمه للصور
السوداني
وتقدم الامارات المساعدات يعني
كثيره لسولان يعني انت الان يعني
دائما نغدر دورا الامارات
[موسيقى]
هي الامارات دائما فيها خارجيه حكيمه
ومتواجد يعني ونحن علاقاتنا طيبه
جدا شكرا جزيلا لك السفير عبد الرحمن
الشرف في سفير السودان في ابوظبي
يعقوب ودي مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم الملفت
للنظر بانه بجانب حرب الدبابات وحرب
يعني
سلاح طائرات وغيرها والمدافع هناك حرب
بيانات ايضا بين الطرفين قوات الدعم
السريع وكذلك القوات الجيش اريد ان اسال
اولا عن كيفيه التعامل تعامل هذين الطرفين
في هذه الحرب مع الاعلام كيف ترين الان
لا طرف راضي ولكن خالد
يعني سابدا لك من مواقف ربما مبكره قليلا
مع بدايه هذه الازمه والساعات الاولى لهذا
الاجتماك كانت دعم السريع في الحقيقه
متفوق اعلاميا على الجيش بالبيانات
بالتعامل مع كل وسائل الاعلام المختلفه
ربما للجيش لان لديه ناطق رسمي واحد او
المعلومات تصدر من جهه واحده وربما يكون
هناك ضغط كثير كان هناك قصور في التعامل
الاعلامي لكن بعد ذلك اختلف الامر قليلا
الدعم السريع ايضا كان يبث فيديوهات بعد
التاكد
وجنه ان هذه الفيديوهات هي حقيقيه وليست
كاذبه مثلا كما كان يقول الجيش ولكن تم
تصويرها في وقت مبكر جدا اي انها مع
الساعات الاولى وتم اطلاقها مثلا مع اليوم
الثالث لهذه الاشتباكات على الجانب الاخر
ايضا الجيش يعتبر نفسه انه هو الجيش هو
القوات المسلحه ان هذه قوات متمرده وايضا
يرى ان الاعلام يجب ان يتعامل بهذه
الطريقه وليس بطريقه الحياد
والعرض الاراء بصوره دائمه لانك تاتي
ببيان للدعم السريع ثم ذلك بيان من الجيش
بعد ذلك تحدث قاده الجيش هنا اعطوا دفعه
اكبر للاعلام كان هناك تعامل جيد مع مختلف
القنوات الاخباريه كانت هناك تصريحات ايضا
قويه بالتالي الان
ذهبت الكفه الى جانب اخر بعد ان كانت في
البدء هي للدعم السريع لكن طبعا لا احد
سيرضى عنك انا اذكر ان انه جاءتنا ملاحظات
على اداء الزميل نزار بقداوي وهو في مروي
في
الساعات الاولى او قبل الاشتباك لم يكن
الدعم السريع راضي عن تغطيه نزار قبل
الاشتباك وايضا لم يكن الجيش راضي على
تغطيته فقلت لنزار طالما ان الطرفين غير
راضيين عن فانت تذهب الان بطريق صحيح فلا
يهمك طالما انت تغطي وجهات النظر المختلفه
لكن هذه الحياديه لا تدفع في اجواء الحرب
لانها قد تعرض في حقيقه كثير من الزملاء
للخطوره ولاوضاع خطيره يجب هنا تحري الدقه
خاصه انه اذا كان هناك اي فيديو او اي
معلومات تم نشرها في القناه وجدنا انها
مفبركه هذا الامر يؤثر بصوره مباشره على
المراسل الموجود في الميدان لذلك تحري
الدقه الان سيكون مضاعف الاهتمام
بعرض المواقف
هذا مقطع فيديو
للجيش يعلنوا فيه الاستيلاء على مخزن
ذخيره تابع للدعم في منطقه جبل الاولياء
مخزن
السريع
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
جبل كان المليان كل الجبل مليان ضحايا
مخزن التالي
ميه من
تفرض المعارك والقائمه بين قوات الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه عده سيناريوهات
على مستقبل سودا منها سيناريوهات قادمه
انفجار هائل وسط الخرطوم دخان اسود كثيف
يصنع مشهدا قاتما للسودان احتمالاته هي ان
يفوز البرهان في المعركه وتنشق جماعه
حميدتي ان يفوز حميدتي ويتبعثر الجيش
وتدخل البلاد حربا اهليه نزاع يستمر
لسنوات طوال بين لا غالب ولا مغلوب يصطلح
الطرفان ويقتسمان الصلاحيات وهو سيناريو
الذي يتمناه السوداني
قد تحسم المعركه عسكريا في بعض المناطق في
السودان لكن الصراع قد يطول بسبب
التقسيمات القبليه والسياسيه لكلا الطرفين
المتنازعين هذا معناه اننا امام مرحله من
الصراع الطويل الامد للاسف الشديد سوف
تستمر الامور هي على هذا النحو فتره اطول
مما هو يعني
السيناريو الذي يرجوه السودانيون هو
المصالحه يلتقي حميدتي والبرهان ويتفقان
على دمج قوه الدعم السريع مع القوات
المسلحه ليكون للسودان جيش واحد يحفظ
الامن ويلبي امنيات هذا الطفل الصغير
شايفين الدمار
شايفين الدمار يا ناس
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا المستشار في
الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والامنيه اللواء الدكتور معتصم عبد القادر
الحسن دكتور معتصم اهلا وسهلا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه
العسكري الاكثر ترجيحا بعد خمسه ايام من
المواجهات المحتدمه في العاصمه الخرطوم
يعني المركز الرئيسي ربما اليوم لهذه
الحرب
[موسيقى]
العربيه على الاستضافه وتحيه للشهاده
المشاهدين
اولا السيناريو المتوقع كما نصب له الجيش
السوداني الجلسه تم جره الى هذه المواجهه
لانه فتحا على دمج قوات ما كان يسمى لقوات
السريع
ولكن عقليه
ولذلك هي كانت تعتقد انها يمكن ان يكون
لها تاثيرا
سياسيا سودانيه دون الجيش السوداني
يقول لها مستغله
في سياسه وفي جيش البلد فالجيش السوداني
الذي هو يعتنقه
باصل
وكما في كل الدول في العالم اي دوله في
العالم
سيكون هنالك خللا كبيرا في بنيتها
لم نرى في اي دوله من دول العالم ان هنالك
الانشاء اي دوله
هنالك اشتراك في الحكم وهنالك اشتراك في
كثير اداء العمل السياسي وهنالك تناح
وهنالك تشاحج لذلك نحن لا نريد ان يكون
كذلك الان
ما كان يسمى بقوات الدعم تم حلها يوم
ين
وجهها سيتم اس
تيعابه له واما واما اي حديث على الصلح او
ان اي سيناء اخر غير ان تكون قوات الدعم
داخل القوات المسلحه انا اعتقد ان هذا ضرب
من الخيانه خصوصا بعد ان تكفدت السودان
يعني انت تميل الى اي سيناري والحسم
السريع الدم عفوا التجميد الذهاب الى الى
حرب طويله ام ماذا
للتوقعات المستقبليه سيد الفاضي في
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه تطلع للدراسات
المساله التي لا هنالك
لكن الامر في الحاله السودانيه الان
استطاعها الجيش كسرت شوكه ما كان يسمى
بالدعم السريع وسوف يدخله طايعا مختارا
اذا بقي منه شيء في القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وستبقى هي الجيش الاوحد للسودان
الذي يكون هنالك اي شكل اشكال المصالحه او
المهادنه في هذه ما يتم ان الجيش سيتخلص
قريبا من قوات الدعم السريع وقيادته بشكل
نهائي هدم ترجحه يعني ام ماذا
لا انا قلت لك ان الجيش يتخلص لم يتخلص في
الماضي تخلص
الان السريع صار شيئا من ماضي السودان سوف
يدرس في كتب التاريخ لن يكون له اي مستقبل
في جيش السودان وفي الحياه السياسيه في
السودان ذلك تلك القوات لم تكن هي بالحزب
السياسي ولم تكن فيها بالقوات المسلحه
المحترفه التي اد
وارها كل السودانيات تمرد على قياده الجيش
السوداني اشعلت الحرائق في السودان دمرت
مخازن الوقود في المطارات دمرت المط
ارات شرح الجنود الاجانب اعتزل على
السفراء في الاتحاد الاوروبي واغاب
له العلم المناعه اعتقد عن المغنيين جوات
كت
ست حدثت الجنود داخل المدن
ويعطينا الان هم يهمون على
وجود
السودان لذلك هذه الاشياء كلها
في اي دوله في اي لحظه من تاريخ السودان
من الان فصاعدا
قبل الوصول الى هذه النتيجه دكتور معتصم
انا اتحدث عن الحرب الان الدائره في شوارع
الخرطوم في كل المناطق تقريبا هذه الحرب
الى اي
مدى ستستمر خاصه وان المعلد من قبل
الطرفين ان الاقتتال سيستمر ربما حتى
الموت او ان يسيطر احدهما على الاخر سيطره
تامه هذا هل هو سيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا
الان وكم سياخذ وقت هذا سؤالي
الان تلاحظ من خلال التغطيه الاعلاميه في
اليوم السابقين صباحا كانت التغطيه
شبكه شبكه
عكس ذلك تماما يعني
هو يقول بان هناك سيطره على اكثر من مكان
اكثر من جهه هناك حرب كروه فرق كما يرى
الكثير من المتابعين في اكثر من منطقه
لا توجد حرب الان لا توجد هنالك عمليات
تطهير وتوظيف لفلوس والجيوب من ما كان
يسمى الدعم الان هم في المناطق الخرطوم
نتعامل معهم الجيش السوداني تعامل جراحي
دقيق
كيلانيين مثل ما احدثوه في الايام الفائته
لا توجد حرب الان
[موسيقى]
مناطق الخرطوم هنالك عده تطهيرها والتعامل
معها الان بالقوات الخاصه السودانيه التي
تبذل جوده مقدره في السيطره عليها باقل
امكانيات وبقل
ش في الوسط شكرا
في الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والامنيه
الله اكبر هذه الدبابه امامكم
19/4/2023 11 12 الله اكبر مباشر مباشر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
في سياق الوضع الصحي الصعب في السودان
دهنت منظمه الصحه العالميه بشده الهجمات
التي تعرض لها الموظفون الصحيون والمرافق
الصحيه والسيارات الاسعاف وقالت المنظمه
في بيان ان هذه الهجمات اخذه في الازدياد
وتسببت في مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص على الاقل
واصابه اثنين اخرين وشارت المنظمه الى ان
هذه الهجمات تحد من امكانيات حصول
المواطنين على الرعايه اللازمه الامر الذي
يعرض مزيدا من الارواح للخطر وعبرت منظمه
الصحه العالميه عن كالقيها اثر التقارير
التي تحدثت عن ضرب المرافق الصحيه ونهبها
واختطاف سيارات الاسعاف والفتاه منظمه
الصحه الى ان الهجمات على العاملين
والمنشات الصحيه انتهاك صارخ للقانون
الدوري مطالبه جميع الاطراف بضمان الوصول
الامن للمرضى والعاملين في المستشفيات
في نشره سابقه مع العربيه حضر سكرتير
نقابه اطباء السودان من ان اعداد النازحين
جراء الاقتتال الداخلي في السودان ترتفع
مطالبا المتحاربين من الطرفين بعدم المساس
بالمواطنين والكوادر الطبيه
نتابع عمليات نزوح كبيره من الخرطوم هنا
ونؤكد ونجدد طلبا لطرفي الصراع بعدم
المساس بالمواطنين وعدم تعريض حياتهم
للخطر وعدم تعرضهم لاي عنف في طريقهم الى
اهاليهم في الولايات ما تابعناه وما راجع
عن معلومات خطيره نرجو ان لا تتكرر ونرجو
ايضا محافظه على ارواحهم كذلك نطالب
بتامين الكوادر الطبيه وفتح مسارات امنه
لها
الوضع الانساني سيء للغايه في السودان
عموما وعلى وجه الخصوص ولايه الخرطوم او
اكد لك ان 39 مستشفى مستشفى كبير نعول
عليهم كثيرا توقف تماما جزء منهم داخل
الخرطوم وجزء خارج الخرطوم ايضا
نقص الامدادات الطبيه والمعينات وكذلك
الغذاءات يشكل هاجس كبير تم اخلاء عدد من
المستشفيات في من قلب الخرطوم لانعدام
الامن فيها لذلك نحن نجدد طلبه لطرفي
الصراع لوقت هذه الحرب العباسيه فورا وفتح
مجالات ومسارات امنه لخروج الجرحى
والمصابين وتوصيل المعينات الانسانيه
للمستشفيات
الخرطوم على الدكتور علي بشير نائب رئيس
اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء في
السودان الدكتور مرحبا بك هل النهار الان
القطاع الصحي في في الخرطوم تحديدا
[موسيقى]
تشهد ذويه صواريخ وعزيز الطائرات واصوات
المدافع الرشاشه واسر تمزح نزوح داخلي الى
بعض الاحياء واخرى الى الولايات وهنالك
حالات للنهب والسلب من بعض العصابات ومن
بعض جنود احدى القوتين المتقاتلتين حقيقه
مع وضع لا يذر بخير نحن الان نتجه نحو
كارثه حقيقيه ستمزق هذه العاصمه للاسف
الشديد
ونخشى ان يستمر هذا الوضع وان يتمدد الى
بقيه الولايات تقنيا خروج مستشفى عن
الخدمه الدكتور علي
دكتور علي بشير
ما الذي يعنيه خروج مستشفى عن الخدمه
تقنيا يعني داخل الاليات العمل في
المستشفى
خروج مستشفى عن الخدمه يعني انه لما لم
اما انه تعرض لقصف وبالتالي فقد الامداد
المائي والكهربائي وبالتالي يصعب
المصابين وعلاجهم بدون اجهزه طبيه واما ان
هنالك
ان الاسقاف لم يصل اليه
هو انه اصبح غير امنوا في مرمى النيران
ولذلك يتم الفحم الكوادر الطبيه والمرضى
الى بعض المستشفيات التي انهار بلغت
ساعتها
الكامله بالتالي 39 مستشفى التي خرجت عن
الخدمه كلها تعرضت للقصف
اخرجت وضح لي في هذا الاطار
ذلك عدد
عدد تسعه مستشفيات هي التي تعرضت للقصف
مستشفى تعرضت للاخلاء القسري
تعرضت 16 مستشفى 25 نتحدث وماذا عن ال 14
المتبقيه
الوصول اليها من قبل القادر الطبي او حتى
المصابين كما ان هنالك
عرفت اسعاف تعرضت للاعتداء من قبل القوات
العسكريه اخرى لم يسمح لها بالعبور الى
تلك المستشفيات كانت لجنه الاطباء
وكذلك منظمات الصحه ربما الدوليه تعرضت
الى نقطه
هناك حالات الاستهداف في المستشفيات بسبب
تحولها الى مرتكزات عسكريه هل هذا حقيقي
هناك من ياخذ هذه المستشفيات كرهينه او
كمكان ربما
ليطلق منه
يعني اي قذائف اتجاه الطرف الاخر
الرئيسي هو خطا في تخصيتك وتوزيع هذه
المستشفيات
وتوزيع
المناطق العسكريه داخل العاصمه معظم
المستشفيات هي بالقرب من مناطق العسكريه
وبالتالي هذا جعلها ان تكون هي عرضه
لنيران المتبادله من قبل الطرفين لذلك
خطوره هذا الامر يعني ان اعداد الذين
سيموتونه بالامراض الاخرى
بفشل اسعاف سيكون اكثر من الذين يموتون
مباشرهم بالرصاص قالوا ان الم في داخل
ولايه هي لا تقدم فقط على المواطنين داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم وانما يتم تحويل لها من
الولايات الاخرى هذه هي مستشفياتها
مستشفيات مرجعيه كما ان الخلافه العاليه
لسكان ولايه الخرطوم الذين يبلقون ربع
سكان السودان الان متواجدونهم في العاصمه
هذه
كارثه حقيقيه
من الذي يستخدم المستشفيات ربما في هذه
الحرب كالدروع او كمرتكزات لاطلاق عمليات
الدعم السريع الجيش
هو يستخدمها مباشره في ارتكاز ولكن
كله كل طرف صفع مستشفى في محيطه فهو
يكون موجود حولها
ويستمر في عمليات القصدون يعني اعطاء ادنى
اولويه لحياه المواطنين يعني
شكرا لك
اشكرك شكرا على هذه الافاده الدكتور علي
بشير نائب رئيس اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه
الاطباء في السودان
سنعود مجددا الى مرايا حيث رصد ايضا مراسل
العربيه حاله من الهدوء النسبي تشهد
المدينه المطله على مطار وقاعده مروي
الجويه العسكريه تاتي هذه الحاله حاله
الهدوء بعد ساعات قليله من اعلان الجيش
سيطرته الكامله على المطار وعلى القاعده
الجويه
نحن الان امام مدخل مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه هذه المدينه التي كان الشاهده
على خمسه ايام من الاشتباكات والعمليات
العسكريه كيف هي الحياه بعد خمسه ايام من
الاشتباكات سنحاول ان ندخل الى مدينه مروي
مباشره لنتعرف على تفاصيل الحياه هنا كيف
هو حال المواطنين في هذه المدينه بعد خمسه
ايام من الاشتباكات سنحاول ان نستمع الى
الصوت الحقيقي صوت المواطن في هذه المحليه
مرحبا بك الان الحمد لله زي ما شفتوها
ونحن قاعدين في مكاتبنا والسوق شغال وكل
حاجه تمام والجماهير وقفت مع الجيش وان
شاء الله كل شئى يكون تمام وانا اطمن
اهلنا في الولايه الشماليه وفي السودان
وخاصه المغتربين بان الامن الان في مريم
وستب 100%
تحت السيطره ما في دعم سريعه عشان
في المطار ولا الدعم السريع في حته
الفلانيه الدعم السريانيه ما عنده تواجد
نهائي في الولايه الشماليه في
كيف الاوضاع في مروي الاوضاع امنه مستغره
والمواطن مرقه سوق لشراء اغراض العيد
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
اذا هذا واقع الحال هنا في مدينه مروي
بالولايه الشماليه بعد خمسه ايام من
عمليات عسكريه واشتباكات مسلحه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع الامور كما تشاهدون
الان في مروي تمضي نحو الهدوء ونحو
الاستقرار لقناه العربيه والحدث نزار
البغداوي من داخل مدينه مروي بالولايه
الشماليه
سلطان المشاع تعلن
انتهاء العمليات استسلام جميع قاده الدعم
السريع واستلام جميع العربات تدمير جميع
القوات وممرات الدعم السريع
الله اكبر الله اكبر تم تدمير العدو تم
تدمير العدو تماما والمهربين الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
نذهب الى الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم مرحبا بك ما هي
اخر مستجدات المواجهات العسكريه في
العاصمه الخرطوم الان
الخبر الذي يتحدث عن الهدنه لمده 24 ساعه
تبدا من السادسه من مساء اليوم الاربعاء
وقال الدعم السريع انه وافق على هذه
الهدنه بينما لم يعد الجيش السوداني حتى
هذه اللحظه على هذه
الهدنه من موافقته من عدمها ايضا في سياق
اخر كذلك هناك مناشدات كثيره منها بمناسبه
نقابه الصحفيين السودانيين التي تناشد
الجهاد الاختصاص والمنظمات الدوليه
بالتدخل العادل والفولي للجلاء المتبقي من
العاملين في الهيئه القوميه للاذاعه
والتلفزيون وهي التي من يوم السبت الورديه
الورديه يوم السبت ذكرت نقابه الصحفيين في
الهيئه العامه للاذاعه والتلفزيون ان هناك
محتجزين في المباني في مدينه ام درمان وتم
الى عدد منهم لكن البقيه
يعني موجودون في الهيئه القوميه للعود
التلفزيون يتعرض العاملون هناك
والتعرض الاصابه المميته القتال الدائر
بالقرب مباني الهيئه هنا
تناشد ايضا نقابه الصحفيين في السلطات
بضروره الالتزام بالهدنه المعلنه وفتح
الممرات العالميه
هذه اخر ردود الافعال حول موضوع الخدمه
التي وافق عليها الدعم السريع والى هذا
الموافق علينا الجيش السوداني في مجمل
الاحوال هناك
الطرق الناري متقطع في مناطق متفرقه من
الخرطوم بالاضافه الى استخدام بعض
المضادات الطيران كذلك في مناطق مختلفه
مختلفه كذلك هناك ايضا طائرات من الدفاع
الجوي السوداني وهي كانت تحلق منذ الصباح
اليوم حتى قبل قليل هذه ابرز الاحداث على
الارض
ابقى معي سالم سنذهب لمتابعه ربما هذه
الصور التي وردتنا قبل قليل
هذه الصور التي تظهر ربما انتشارا او
تكدسا لمجموعه من الجثث في بعض مناطق
الخرطوم وشوارعها الخرطوم التي تشهد
المواجهات
العسكريه المسلحه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم ما الذي رصدتموه حول هذه
النقطه تحديدا مساله انتشار الجثث في
شوارع العاصمه
نعم هناك انتشار لموضوع الجثث وهي مساله
انسانيه غايه في الخطوره
هي في مناطق مختلفه للاسف في ولايه
الخرطوم هناك تكدس في مجموعه من الجثث هذه
المره في الشوارع
في شوارع الخرطوم المختلفه التي كانت مكان
الاقتتال هو مكان النزاع والحروب او
ميادين القتال صحه العباره في هناك مثلا
في
درمان هناك جثث كثيره جدا ايضا في مناطق
مختلفه كذلك وربما الصور ايضا الصور كثيره
جدا وابشع مما هو على الشاشه كذلك لكن في
المجمل هناك المناسبات حينما جاءت
المناشدات فيما يتعلق
بمساله الهدنه لجنه اطباء السودان
المركزيه وايضا مجموعه من النقابات التي
لها علاقه بالعمل الصحي تحدثت عنهم تقدس
الجثث هذه ايضا الهدنه تاتي من اجل يعني
رفع هذه الجثث من الممرات والشوارع بالامس
كذلك وزير الداخليه اوكل الى الدفاع
المدني هذه المهمه كذلك من المهام المنقله
الى الدفاع المدني بعد المهم التي في
توجيه المياه لمياه الشرب في الاماكن التي
لا توجد بها مياه وكذلك
الاشتراك على اصلاح الاعطال المتعلقه
بالمياه وايضا
وكذلك الكهرباء ايضا اكلت اليه مهمه يعني
رفع هذه القطط من الشوارع في الاماكن التي
توجد بها هذه الجسد وايضا توفير بعد ذلك
الممرات الامنه وتحديدها للسيارات الاسعاف
وايصال الطبيه للمستشفيات
وكما اصول الكوادر الطبيه في امان
هل يمكن الحديث عن عالقين ومحتجزين ايضا
في بعض الاحياء المحاصره جراء هذه
المواجهات سالم
بالنسبه للمحتجزين هناك كل يوم يعني تاتي
تصلنا انباء لمحتجزين في مكان ما نحاول
الاتصال بهم لمعرفه تفاصيل هذا الاحتجاز
حقيقه هناك مشكله في التواصل معهم لكن
بالنظر لهذا الملف المحتجزين يفهم ان
المحتجزين ربما اكثر من الذين ظهروا على
وسائل الاعلام سواء او حتى
مرضى الكلى وغيرهم من المحتجزين حتى
تلاميذ في المدرسه هناك ايضا مؤسسات ايضا
اخرى فيها العديد في واحد من البنوك ايضا
فيه محتجزين كذلك
فنجد ان الملف المحتاجزين لا يمكن حله الا
بهذه الهدنه هذه الان ايضا هي العمل لدعوه
التلفزيون فيها محتجزين كذلك
هذا الامر يحل بالهدنه وجود الهدنه هذا
بوجهه النظر نقابه
الصحافه نقابه
الاعلاميين السودانيين هي التي اكدت على
هذا المعنى هناك ايضا سالم تتحدث عن
اشتباكات عنيفه الان في منطقه جبره بجوار
منزل حميتي قائد قوات الدعم السريع هل من
معلومات اكثر تفصيلا لكي لدي
نعمل هذه المنطقه منطقه جبرا التي فيها
الاشتباك منذ الامس كانت فيها اشتباكات
عنيفه جدا
في في منطقه جبرا وكانت اعمده الدخان
واللعب في مناطق مختلفه كذلك من هذه
المنطقه
ايضا صباح اليوم كانت هناك اشتباكات عنيفه
كذلك في منطقه جبره وايضا تتجدد هذه
الاشتباكات بين الفينه والاخرى لكن بوجود
هذه الاشتباكات يفهم انه لم يوصل بعد ذلك
لم يغسل كل طرف الى هدفه ولا تاكيدات
وشاهدت عن تواجد حميدتي في هذا المكان في
هذا المقر او في هذا المنزل
ايضا من الصعب جدا الحسم بهذه القضيه
بوجود حمد في داخل منزله لان اذا افترضنا
هذه الفرضيه من حيث وجوده يمكن ايضا هناك
فرضيات اخرى تقول انه ليس متواجد في منزله
يمكن ان يكون في واحد من المكاتب او في
المنزل الذي يقع بالقرب من بيت الضياف
كذلك له بيت اخر هنالك في بيت الضيافه
بعيد داخل القياده العامه للجيش ليس هناك
استبعاد كذلك ان يكون هناك
حتى خارج البلاد كلها نظريات موجوده لكن
شكرا هذه المنطقه المنطقه الجبرا تشهد
اشتباكات متكرره شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم تعطيتنا
مستمره زميله ميسون عزام تسحبكم على راس
الساعه الان الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات